are you here for the free pilot training
that's awesome because today on lesson
18 we'll be discussing class d
airspace we're going to be talking about
everything you need to know as a private
pilot to go into this airspace
so sit back and relax and let's knock
out some studying
class d airspace is controlled airspace
that surrounds smaller towered airports
usually it's cylinder shaped with a 5
statute mile radius
that starts at the surface and goes up
to 2500
agl but to get the exact specs we need
to look at a vfr sectional of the
airport we want to fly into
we can tell we're looking at class delta
airspace by this blue segmented circle
surrounding the airfield
the segmented circle is telling us that
this airspace starts at the surface
but don't be fooled when you see a
magenta segmented circle
this is actually class echo airspace
that starts at the surface
the way i remember the difference is
that this magenta airfield in the center
means this airport is not
towered when you see a blue airport like
this
it means that the airfield has a tower
and class delta airspace is designed for
smaller towered airports
now we already mentioned that class d
airspace starts at the surface
but if you want to know where the top is
look inside this little square right
here
this altitude is expressed in hundreds
so the top of this class delta airspace
is 3500
msl now occasionally you'll see this
number with a minus sign in front of it
this just means that the airspace goes
up to but does not include
the 3500 msl so if i'm flying my
airplane at 3500 msl here
technically i'm not in the class delta
airspace
all right let's look at some of the
rules we need to know before we can go
into class delta
first we must establish two-way radio
communications with atc prior to entry
then we must maintain those
communications while within that
airspace
do these rules look familiar yeah
they're the exact same ones for class
charlie airspace
let's call up joplin regional they look
like a nice place to stop for fuel
before i call them up i'll make a quick
mental note of exactly where i
am then i'll grab the adis joplin tower
cessna 5678 papa 10 miles to the
southeast
inbound with yankee sometimes it can be
beneficial to let atc pick the runway
for you
that's why here from my request i just
told them that i'm inbound
aircraft calling shea altitude
oh shoot i forgot to tell them my
altitude but first
can i enter the airspace yet nope
not yet they haven't said our call sign
joplin tower this is cessna 5678 papa at
2 000 feet
yeah chestnut 5678 papa joplin tower we
see you now
altimeter three zero zero two make right
base for runway three
six when you hear this the first thing
that should go through your head is
i can go in now but i haven't been
cleared to land yet
when they tell you which runway they
want you to use this is not the same as
getting a landing clearance
three zero zero two right base for
runway three six
cessna five six seven eight papa all
they need to hear is the basic
information
all the numbers and your call sign
session of five six seven eight papa
joplin tower you're number two now
following a piper cub on one mile
final clear to land runway 3-6
okay now i'm cleared to land but there's
somebody in front of me
we need to try to find that guy and let
the tower know when we see him
then at the very least we need to repeat
our landing clearance back to tower
but i think i just spotted him traffic
in sight clear to land runway 36 cessna
5678 papa
next let's take a quick look at the vfr
weather minimums for class delta
airspace
once again this is the worst weather we
can have and still be able to fly vfr in
this airspace
we need to have at least three statute
miles of visibility
then we need to stay away from the
clouds
we need to stay at least 500 feet below
the clouds
2000 feet away from the sides and a
thousand feet away from the tops
and if you remember from the last lesson
this is the exact same
weather minimums as class c air space
don't forget our memory aid of 3152
or three cessna 152s
as far as our equipment requirements are
concerned all we need to go into class
delta is a working
two-way radio how else are we going to
talk to that crusty old controller from
joplin
to operate in delta you don't need adsb
or a transponder
hey i hope you learned something today
don't forget to smash like for me before
you get out of here
and if you haven't already don't forget
to subscribe and hit the bell
notification
and i'll see you on the next episode of
free
pilot training
you